Isn't that cool?
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Design -- I love its design.
I remember when I was little, my mom asked me,
"Would you like to play the violin or the piano?"
I looked at that giant monster and said to myself --
"I am not going to lock myself on that bench the whole day!"
(Laughter)
This is small and lightweight.
I can play from standing, sitting or walking.
And, you know what?
The best of all is that if I don't want to practice,
(Whispering) I can hide it.
(Laughter)
The violin is very beautiful.
Some people relate it as the shape of a lady.
But whether you like it or not, it's been so for more than 400 years,
unlike modern stuff [that] easily looks dated.
But I think it's very personal and unique that,
although each violin looks pretty similar,
no two violins sound the same --
even from the same maker or based on the same model.
Entertainment -- I love the entertainment.
But actually, the instrument itself isn't very entertaining.
I mean, when I first got my violin and tried to play around on it,
it was actually really bad,
because it didn't sound the way I'd heard from other kids --
it was so horrible and so scratchy.
So, it wasn't entertaining at all.
But besides, my brother found this very funny:
Yuk! Yuk! Yuk!
(Laughter)
A few years later, I heard a joke
about the greatest violinist, Jascha Heifetz.
After Mr. Heifetz's concert,
a lady came over and complimented him:
"Oh, Mr. Heifetz, your violin sounded so great tonight!"
And Mr. Heifetz was a very cool person,
so he picked up his violin and said,
"Funny -- I don't hear anything."
(Laughter)
Now I realize that as the musician,
we human beings, with our great mind, artistic heart and skill,
can change this 16th-century technology and a legendary design
to a wonderful entertainment.
Now I know why I'm here.
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
At first, I thought I was just going to be here to perform,
but unexpectedly, I learned and enjoyed much more.
But ... although some of the talks were quite up there for me.
(Laughter)
Like the multi-dimension stuff.
I mean, honestly, I'd be happy enough
if I could actually get my two dimensions correct in school.
(Laughter)
But actually, the most impressive thing to me is that --
well, actually, I would also like to say this for all children
is to say thank you to all adults, for actually caring for us a lot,
and to make our future world much better.
Thank you.
(Applause)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)